dans cette décharge sauvage les ordures
s'accumulent
il y à du bois des carcasses de voitures
ou encore une armée de pneus plus
inquiétant on trouve aussi de l'amiante
et toutes sortes de solvants alban
bernard via moins de 500 mètres de cette
déchetterie
depuis 2007 il voit la plaine se remplir
de détritus
il ya 11 ans quand je venais ici avec
mes enfants faire du vélo on pouvait
circuler aujourd'hui
là il ya des zones où on n'y a même plus
de chemin pour sauver cet espace il a
créé un site internet est lancé une
pétition
plus de 2000 personnes l'ont d'ores et
déjà signé il a répertorié au total plus
de soixante et une zone envahie par les
déchets et là on est sur la mer des
déchets derrière moselle l'océan des
déchets mais là c'est la mer des déchets
qui représente quand même presque
presque
ouais deux hectares 3 ha complet depuis
l'année dernière le volume de détritus à
tripler chaque jour des camions enchaîne
les va-et-vient comme en témoigne cette
vidéo amateur tournée par un riverain
aujourd'hui la sécurité a été renforcée
autour du site
ces plots en béton tente de faire
barrage et des policiers multiplient les
patrouilles
pourtant les déchets continuent de
s'entasser on s'est vite aperçu que les
plaques minéralogiques étaient fausses
ou étaient des plaques minéralogiques
roumaine donc la possibilité
d'intervenir et d'avoir une action
efficace pour mettre un terme à tout ça
est très réduite notamment par la
verbalisation
moi ce que j'aimerais justement c'est
que la législation évolue et qu'on
puisse saisir le véhicule même pour une
suspicion de dépôts sauvages
la remise en état du site est évalué à
un million d'euros
mais le coup pourrait être revu à la
hausse des projets de nettoiement et de
redynamisation sont à l'étude comme la
culture du miscanthus une plante qui
dépollue les sols et là on est en train
de travailler sur cette phase 2 de cette
opération qui consiste à la fois à
dépolluer par la culture de miscanthus
qui permet de capter le plomb mais
également de porter des cultures un peu
novatrice comme la culture culture hors
sol
le combat continue pour les riverains de
la plaine de carrières sous poissy
ils se mobiliseront le 31 mars prochain